dafür bewies geht ich habe ich leute
bevor wir das nicht noch eine ganz kurze
info ich habe da zu weihnachten 2017
merger ausgebracht werden jetzt aus
dieser kollektion auch mal ein paar
teile nach produziert eine ganz kleine
serie und die kommt um 15 25 uhr online
link dazu in der beschreibung das heißt
wenn ihr damals nicht bekommen habe oder
jetzt was wollt unbedingt abchecken
15.25 uhr ist die lounge und danach was
es mit der kreuzung und die gibt es erst
geht's und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge kommt können wir folgen
jetzt willkommen zur ersten folge von
stadt land spaß meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren leute das prinzip ist
das gleiche wie bei stadler und youtube
ab der bestimmte mal gesehen wir haben
konzerte wie immer verschiedene
kategorien richtig zeigen
es wird dann zufällig ein buchstabe
ausgewählten hatte suchen alle möglich
schnell ist jeder kategorie etwas zu
schreiben wenn man etwas in der
kategorie hat wo keiner was hat was
zählt man dafür 20 punkte wenn zwei
leute was in die kategorie haben aber
das kann da hat aber weiter was in der
kategorie haben 17 dafür denn in zweiter
ist gleich aufgeschrieben haben fünf
wenn man nix 60 und für die anderen
pferde sondern gehalten haben die
kategorien leute werden stadtplan spaß
name für babys kind dann auf janas
wunsch in top-positionen das heißt so
viel wie könnte ich wahrscheinlich
denken so sechs stellung der rapper
grund mit youtube aufzuhören und am ende
natürlich die punkte für die kategorie
und wir legen jetzt los
die zehn hoch von exakt stoffen plätze
fertig
halt stopp die macht derweil dass ich
vorn mit der stadt ich habe regensburg
ich habe das auch eine gute stadt auf
jeden fall anabolika anabolika breckel
draußen und weiter zu sehen dann land
womit das ist ein flug strich ist
rumänien russland
ich habe andere schlacht ich glaube wir
sind alle eine was ist passiert wird das
war ein riesen verlief anständig passt
dazu habe ich nichts was besonders
deutlich und ledige da hättest du ri
ich habe das falsch
die proben werden sich von terry a
brands hat mir angerufen
ok zu den highlights zählten theorien
zählt namen von libeskind rudolph ich
habe roland heintze roland einfach die
proposition ok meine position fest
reverse cowgirl ein professionelles
rückwärts meine position ist pro sekunde
bekommt kaum verrücktes punkte ja
definitiv nein zu sagen ja und ich
kriegen beim rodeo es gibt vielleicht
das heißt sie sitze sondern brauchen und
er probiert ihr untergebracht
sondern vorderseite text eigentlich im
bett ist was ich durchmache rückwärts
auf dem stuhl ist das einzige video auf
der habenseite ist jetzt auf dem stuhl
und da ist es nicht nur der position
weil dies alleine in dem video gut dann
der rapper bligg los rennt ok serbien
grund mit youtube-videos gerade auch
seine richter
rassismus was ist die rückwärtige
kriegst du wirst du wissen willst
youtube und er findet dann max runter
sagt stock berlin ist übrigens keine
kann
dann fangen wir an mit stadt berlin und
ich bin alt ist der trainer ich habe
extra bis heute für berg im land
bulgarien hier auf junge bad banks das
ist natürlich keine anstalten gegen so
fairbanks aber wie sagst du zu wechseln
was videos hoch so irina in minecraft
schwimmer zu und dies dann halt mit dem
man damit b kaders werden teilweise aber
er sagt ver.di bescheid
deswegen offizier punkt würde ich hier
kann dann nahm für babys kind vielleicht
zwei geschrieben zählt nicht ich habe ja
wast opposition sieht schon mal lustig
und muss ich sagen mag es für payback
das war echt nicht auferweckt aber keine
position nicht mehr weg ist glaube ich
sex ohne kondom
ich habe top-position job natürlichste
position ist kein papa ja und du kriegst
du das was wir jetzt auch noch gesehen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die zwei jahren dass die zwei komplett
weg rapper ich habe gesagt ja ich habe
sie denn da gibt es halt bunt mit bei
mir sitzungszeit steht den fluss
patentes macht fußball klassiker ist
also bald problem ist ein wurden mit den
flossen bei kritikers zum beispiel die
sportler nicht
ich habe profil getroffen also sinnvoll
kumpel ok alles klar gut jetzt jammert
runter ich sagt stock das gibt es ja
nicht
doch nicht max und wer ist doch von der
ich bring dich da schaltet faktisch nach
jährige kiefer mehr statt
ich hab greensville wussten dies genug
mich weil rangers ins park rangers und
wahrscheinlich die screens welcher
irgendwo in kappel ausgleich
das ist aber auch nicht so dass man sich
über das aber sind und oft ist es gibt
kriterien marvel bis ins spaßbad eigenen
namen ausdenken ich habe querfeld gibt
es ja westhus gleichmäßig coesfeld oder
irgend sowas
das bitte ich glaube das liegt erfurt
[Musik]
kleine rote karte ich habe auf deutschen
k wir sind aber in eigener regie
mahlstedt kreatur fest ich scheiße ist
kein spaß soll das denn dass du ich habe
karten können auch mal fehler fenja also
der ist aber okay der ist hat er doch
vor das ego der ist ja auch gestern
fußballer heute kann es mal ab jetzt ich
hab' quasimodo also motor ist fast
ausnahmslos kind habe ich quäle da ist
was schon solche gerne freiwillig dieser
fünfter in die den abhängt wird kleiner
quentin
ich habe auch keine halbe dorf bis
jemand anders ist nachhaltiges kenntnis
das ist das scheiße wie quasimodo szenen
wirklich nur eine höhere kosten
richtiger name damit war auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihr könnt die
geister so dass das ist sehr wertvoll
position ich habe die stärke des bebens
quatsch vorbei
ich hatte quer löffelchen also für alle
wirklich alle zehn bei mir selber wir
sind nicht auf dem bekannten
amerikanischen küste ist bei ich nicht
versprechen haben wir bringen
hast du mit sonst of sax beruf youtube
das ist heute glücklich ich habe gründe
die du auf salat mischen barak und
machst du quelle der inspiration
versichert euro für dich schlecht aber
gefällt
über 70 amazonen und diskuswerferin
zwischen herren günter quelle der
inspiration für das macht okay ich habe
quasi kann ich nix mehr
okay okay jetzt maxim wieder ist der
stopp letzte ohne stopp stopp fangen wir
an mit stadt im tal und kann statt
irgendwo als ein sprecher in suhl
vermitteln und keine stadt momentan ist
er kernstadt und musste stattdessen im
tal ist nach dessen so einen anstrich
und dabei kannst du schon strich
anhängig so gut aus ja ich hoffe aber
dass das ipo damit er sollte äthiopiens
schneider war weil er nur die tradierung
jahren auf jetzt okay ich hab s land
ziehen dann spaß hier zu fahren ist dann
viel spaß bei der dt
ich habe ehrlich hatte
ich hab's ja immerhin besten gewissen
getrieben dass die null punkte bekommen
würde
ich habe ja aber die ira bleiben denn
ich weiß nicht wie ich und enrico okay
dann top-positionen ein erster ein
verein der sich natürlich ecke ernst
herr minister wird dann rapper das
nichts mehr
ich habe die ski minute und dann habe
ich grundmiete darauf zu hören wie viel
vor sich sehen ja ich habe einfach alles
klar sonst sehen wir zusammen ja dann
gestand ich bin bei 190 m access bei 320
über 280 damit würde sicher für heute
leute max hat diese runde leider gewann
muss man fairerweise sagen überall in
seinem charme verlegt hatte wer ist zum
nächsten mal